you
[Music]
okay my name is Andres Pina I am a
Dayton junior and I work at radical beta
coordinating our R&D activities mainly
radical beet is a product company which
is based in Milano
in Italy and we build up basically two
products the first product is radical
with natural analytics which is a
self-service platform the same to let
users to implement their own analytic
split framework we do it with streaming
technologies and the second broad
product we build up is an SDP which is a
time series database we'll build it on
top of Scala and akka and we we got it
really focused on guaranteeing really
quick view on streaming analytics port
for the view layer along this
presentation I think that you you will
you will listen to a couple of concepts
that you already know but I hope that
you you will find some interesting point
and I think that that's a good start
so I will start from streams what I
would like to say here is that a data
stream is an abstraction over data over
a special type of data where there is a
source and external source that we don't
have command on top of this which is
unknown because we we don't know where
these streams is going to conclude
itself and is also unbounded and a good
thing about streams that with a stream
you can model out also batches so you
can take historical data and process it
as events from the beginning to the end
and as long as streaming has become
important through the industry were too
many times to take all how to manage
streaming with
when when we are handling big data the
first attempt is the so-called Amdur
kita - you have to read if ur entire you
have the first way which is the batch
layer whereby you can run your high
throughput bad jobs and and you collect
you can schedule those jobs you can run
as you wish
in the moment that you prefer and then
you collect the final outcome of your
offer of your processing and then you
have the second layer which is the speed
layer where by Iran streaming jobs so
you have outcomes that are continuously
flowing out to the downstream zone to
the output and then you have two
different kind of results that you need
to merge out in order to provide it to
the end user of course and that was the
first point that the first interesting
point that lambda it had raised and the
second one was how we if we have a bug
if we have new business project to
deploy against those two Slayers how do
we represent Atta in a feasible way and
one of the main problem about lambda
architectures in some cases is that you
have since you have two different layers
you need to handle probably also with
two different code bases and if you
handle with two different code bases if
you have a bug if you have new business
logically business logic you probably
need also to work out against two
different code bases and probably those
two code bases are running on different
frameworks and that means you probably
need also two different kind of
competences within your team and that
also mean that you probably need two
different hardware because both are high
demanding in term of computations and
this kind of issue software with the
second attempt which is so-called the
cop
or that you heard about for ruining the
keynote and the capacitor is a unique
layer which is implementing using stream
processors whereby you have input
sources that are all modeled as a stream
because we can because we can model
batches with data streams and you can
deploy your streaming jobs with a unique
layer and so you you are the coupling
then the problem that we got before but
and this is the architecture we're
trying to implement still if you have to
handle with a copper kettle you need a
system which is at the same time able to
guarantee high throughput and low
latency requirement and at the same time
you need something that let you
represent your data quite easily if you
need to do it and at the same time in
the system that guarantees you that that
you can store your data and persist it
and then you use it at some point and
that is something which is guaranteed by
Kafka of course and Kafka is a streaming
platform at that at the same time
guarantees a durable storage system you
have you can define the retention of
your topics as you wish and at the same
time is a publish and subscribing
messaging system and it's very high
performance it current is you write
performance requirements and for data
reprocessing what you have is that you
can easily read your data as many times
as you want using the offset the offset
the abstraction over the Kafka topic so
each record will be coupled with with
your offset and you can decide if you
want to read your topic since the
beginning since I define offset and so
forth
and of course made up of different
layers and we are going to focus as well
on Kafka streams on the streams API by
this presentation right now Kafka is
yeah it's a sort of standard for for
streaming of streaming application and
what we do with our product and radical
bit is to use Kafka's our backbone we
use it to collect data from external
sources and then we process it using the
streams API and then we integrate the
outcomes towards external system using
the connect GPS but we want also with
our product to guarantee to to build a
framework which is able to to produce
predictive descriptive and predictive
analytics and so we need to integrate
much learning small but when we needed
to do it within a cop architecture which
is our architecture that otherwise the
product was not complete as miss or
being said ok briefly I will show you
two separate tracks the first one is
about model serving so you have your
train model ready to put it in
production and how to serve it within a
copper kettle and the second truck I
will show you is one kind of approach to
train models online okay so model
serving is part of a greater spectrum of
theories which which is called machine
learning logistics whereby you can they
learn you how to how to cope with all
the problems about on Antoine machine
learning pipelines so since the training
and then as long as you have the ready
model that you can you have to maintain
it you have to make the governance of
these models because they are real
assets of companies one of the main
issues with all the serving is that you
have in a some point you have an
handover of these models between
different teams which are basically data
science teams and data engineering teams
so that means that you have two teams
that are working with different
technologies they are using different
tools and probably the model comes from
a framework and that you need to put it
on production with a different framework
so you need to cope with this
fragmentation that you have which is
increased by the the large amount of
tools that both data scientists and the
engineers have to handle machine
learning of course and basically we have
had too many attempts to regulate this
kind of communication protocol between
teams the first one it is the standard
base so you you provide you a standard
as long as the data scientist completes
the deployment the modeling of your
machine learning models then it will
export it in a standard that might be
that might be read from other frameworks
which are running on different systems
and there are samples like predictive
markup model language or o WN x4 for
deep learning and at the first point the
the first attempt the second one which
is gaining momentum right now is the
container based solution so regardless
the underlying system the data science
used to the to model them to model eyes
learning algorithm
it will wrap up the underlying
environment which in a dr. container and
dr. container just have to know how to
use this model to make predictions and
then it will in straight out a
communication protocol that might be
arresting a rest server that will
provide predictions and the main problem
with the standard based solution is that
you need support so you need support
from the tools and which is not easy and
at the same time you can cover a subset
of of models or you cannot go really you
can not really go deeper if you need
that one set features and this is
something that the container based
solution solves for you with the cons
that you need different competences also
about automation so there whoops
competencies what you wanting to achieve
basically is using kafka streams serving
machine learning models against data
streams and we wanted to do in a way
that led us to choose which kind of tool
we want to be implement at the same time
and the main requirement which is
mumbles from the cap architecture is
that basically if we since we are
running on our copper kita so with the
model usually evolves over time so you
have very different versions because the
model is enhancing because something is
changing a different tuning and so forth
so the the streaming job needs to follow
this models evolution as well we want to
it by uploading new jobs deploying new
version of jobs but we want to achieve
it dynamically and so we use the kafka
streams which is a library
through politically along this along
this flight and you have two choices
mainly you have the streams DSL which is
a hydrant level yes cell you have a
second API which is the process API that
if you want to go deeper you can work
with advanced features of cough the
streams and I would like to use this
expand this example will implement and
use the h2o which is us which is a
machine learning and one platform
and as long as the data scientist
completed the modeling of the algorithm
it will it will persist the model as
standard Java objects and and we started
from here with the main objective to
serving h2o models within a Kafka
streams job so the first concept we
introduced is the so-called contra
stream which is a stream that is
bringing metadata across across your
topic and this meta data stream
represents mainly how the model
is defined where the model is located
and how should they ping the model to
towards the internal Kafka stream task
and the generator of this control stream
is a model repository server which is a
sternal service that knows exactly the
the current situation the big picture
about machine learning model within
Europe literature and so we take this
first stream and then what we do is just
to try to broadcast the stream to all
your distributed Kafka streamed tasks
and we use it we implement it using the
global key table concept
so each distributor task will be
self-consistent because it will have the
same picture about your machine learning
models that you need to serve and the
big advantage of this approach is as
long as the data stream comes so we have
a second stream which is the main stream
the thing we need to predict and we we
want to do we want we don't want to do
shuffling right here but we want to let
the stream going through the task we
with the upstream repetition in strategy
so we don't apply shuffling right here
and we can do it because each task in
independent another thing we do is as
long as we build the internals tail of
the task we we don't load the model at
the same time but we we need only the
metadata we are going to load the model
within the task when when the first
event is coming and asked for that model
in this case with h2o we can talk the
model repository server and we download
a POJO model and we beloved it within
the task and you pay a little overloaded
over at at the beginning by the current
ease you that each following
swimming event that will come and
requires for that model we find the
model ready and so in its just it needs
just to keep the prediction and going to
the downstreams and inaudible think
about lazy loading modding is that if
you if your job fails you lose the model
but you retain the metadata so at each
point you will be able to restore also
the model again with the same method so
this one is more or less the
architecture we got for the h2
application but as long as I said we
wanted to serve also other tools other
standards or daughter containers if you
want it so what we did is basically we
try to generalize a couple of concept
within the architecture first of all I
need since I have the control message I
need to tell to the application how
should I build the broadcasted States
the internal state the first the second
generalization is how to build up the
model within within the within the task
so if it is a module we use the java api
provided by h2o if it is a docker
container which is serving the machine
learning model so we build up a rest
client within the task which is able to
call the external dr container which is
serving the model and the latest gen the
last generalization is okay i have the
main stream have the load in machine
learning model okay how how i use
how should i use the the prediction and
how should I beat the outcome to the
down streams and so that if you take the
the architecture use it with h2o and
then with the same strategy you can also
loading PMML models which the standard
based solution
your task and we provided the
implementation in Flint in this case
good but at the same time if you need to
contact external dr. containers you just
need to to load fresh client within your
task ok the second approach I would like
to talk you about is about online
training so how should we approach this
problem if you would like to train model
online you have a different solution the
most common one and we tried we tried
several several way to achieve this call
a standard approach is that you contact
external system that ton of ML
frameworks that let you implement your
machine learning model but another
strategy is the is to is to implement
poor online training models usually a
train you take the data set which is a
perfect data source
it's a batch is an historical data
source and you take all the data so say
you provide to the model all at once and
then the model will learn from the data
and then you will have the final model
what does it happen online online you
can do it in that way because you have a
stream which is infinite and which is
unknown so you need to make out
incremental updates of your model of
your loss functions and probably you
need also to do one event per time and
that brings out several issues about
incremental learning like difficulty to
converge out the model and so forth and
then we have a streaming system so you
have also to handle with the
computational model so you have the
upstream and what it happens usually is
that part of your streams of your stream
this card and part of your stream maybe
is stored within your task and the rest
of the stream is going towards the down
streams and what you cannot do
I mean it's not real pattern is to load
your batches of stream and collated it
everything within the main memory to
make the deep batch update of your
machine learning model and the second
problem that we need to tackle is about
the nature of your of the data because
because you because a stream which is
continually generated is also usually
changing him behavior and this is the
concept described by the concept drift
whereby you need to follow the evolution
of this data and the changing behavior
of your data and in this way just think
about a newspaper which is talking about
domestic affairs and then something
really dramatic or something really
important happens within within your
state and then the users will change it
dramatically they behavior over the
application and you need to cope with
this changing behavior of your users and
about online training online machine
learning algorithm is the main advantage
is that they are first to adopt so they
will follow this changing behavior of of
the data and of course it's a it's a
good shape as long as you you you need
to cope with this with the concept drift
in your application and what we did is
using kafka streams is to implementing a
sort of library so within the same
operator you can choose the
implementation you want you want to use
about an online training algorithm and
we did a couple of implementation I will
show you I will tell you about the
passive-aggressive algorithm which is a
margin based solution and that means
that the algorithm will learn as long as
the classification or the regression
rosen's well the algorithm will
understand if the model is good enough
to be passive so to to don't update the
model with a new enforcing and it is bid
also on the feedback concept that I
would like to describe you with the
slide so suppose that your task is is
the task demanding to train them the
machine learning model what it what it
makes is the so-called preferential
learning so as long as is it takes the
first input it will make the prediction
it will cast out a prediction so it will
say it's not a cool and then what it
happens if you have a second stream
which is a feedback stream that tells
the true class and is something that
passive-aggressive algorithm needs and
it says ok it was a cool actually
so the algorithm will enforce so it will
be aggressive against the loss function
and then with the second input it will
make the right prediction so would they
would say ok that that is a cube okay
you were right with the fitness stream
we know it and then the prediction was
good but the margin of this of the loss
function of the of the good
classification it wasn't big enough so
it will enforce again as long as it will
overcome the margin in that in that case
the algorithm will be passive how
implemented it basically we used the
same the topic to implement both the
unlabeled data which is the data that we
were making prediction against and the
label data so the predict the event with
the right class and then we used the
store concept of cascade of cosmic kafka
streams which allows the developer to
implement the internal task state in a
persistent than for tolerant way and we
used two different store one of for the
model of course and second one for the
event and as long as the label that also
the event with the right class will come
we will eventually update the model and
we will discard the event as long as you
training your model online you need also
to change the way you are measuring the
quality matrix of your model learning
and if you want us with as we see in
this in this life to to measure the
accuracy matrix and so forth in the same
way you usually do with the batch data
set you need first to run with the wall
input data against the model so you have
no quality matrix at the beginning and
then since the second run you can you
can start to measure the accuracy and
but as long as you are training online
your algorithm it is important also how
much time the modest needs to go to
convergence and to learn from the
current stream and as long as a concept
reefa happens how much time the models
it is going to drift they put the
predictions as well
and to conclude about the land training
of course these feedback algorithms are
good if you have feedbacks as well so it
is not something which is usual and but
you can find them in some application as
spam filtering where whereby users gives
in users if in in this way the true
class of the of the email and then the
algorithm will learn will announce its
its quality by using those true classes
so to pour in the bland about modest
serving stream event stream processing
platform is the perfect fit because you
you can guarantee to make prediction
with with your machine learning models
with low latency and height scalability
and yellow problem he is trying
attempting to serve at least in our case
as many frameworks as we can because the
fact violent of course has have
different solutions for deploying
machine learning models for online
learning it's still difficult to find
production as you use cases and
companies sue prefer do batch learning
doing batch learning because it works
basically and but if we think that in
some cases were and nowadays as long as
we are going through a reactive
application a reactive solution we we're
trying we start to think about
implementing the reactive solution also
for machine learning and training and
know 30 minutes I conclude if you want
to come down to the office hour I will
be just right there and I conclude if
you have any questions thank you very
much for listening
[Applause]
[Music]